in venial in one of its main goal is to
bring technology to people in the rural
areas with access with these
technologies make people feel that
they're not very far from from from from
the rest of the world now so they are
connected
one thing we do is installing computer
labs in schools and in the school's most
of the time teachers or students that
never touch a computer before for
something we had never seen it
we give them a whole package solar
panels for power computers and
connectivity we've already trained
almost a hundred teachers boxy is an IT
technician which is basically trained by
envy know most of these bodies have
their own business like small cyber
cafes and one of these men goal is to
connect the schools
we have them spread all over the country
but these bodies they stay in the
communities they work with the people in
the communities he or she is a local
partner he has the skills and
competencies here to keep the work that
Envy new has started going
even after in video goes back and the
work that he has started will continue
moving they have a computer labs in a
school where they can go they can do
research they can communicate with
people all over the world make them feel
that they are not really far from the
rest of the world